- ברוכים השבים ל-Understanding Quantum Information and Computation.
שמי John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך
ב-IBM Quantum.
זהו השיעור השביעי בסדרה ובשיעור הזה נדון בבעיית הערכת הפאזה ואיך אפשר לפתור אותה
עם מחשב קוונטי.
אחר כך נשתמש בהערכת פאזה לבעיית פירוק לגורמים של מספרים שלמים, שדיברנו עליה בשיעור הקודם.
מה שנקבל זה האלגוריתם של Shor, שמאפשר לפרק מספרים שלמים
לגורמים בעלות פולינומית או בזמן פולינומי אם מעדיפים
לחשוב במונחים של הזמן הנדרש ולא במספר
הפעולות הבסיסיות שצריך.
זה היהלום שבכתר של
אלגוריתמים קוונטיים במובן מסוים, ולמרות שפירוק מספרים שלמים גדולים
אולי לא כל כך שימושי לרוב האנשים, זו עדיין אחת ההוכחות
המשכנעות ביותר שיש לנו לטובת ההשערה שמחשבים קוונטיים יציעו
יתרונות דרמטיים
על מחשבים קלאסיים. הנה סקירה של השיעור.
נתחיל עם הגדרת בעיית הערכת הפאזה עצמה, ואחר כך נדון בשיטה לפתור את הבעיה הזו
עם מחשב קוונטי.
ניקח את זה צעד אחר צעד, ונתחיל עם מה שאפשר
לחשוב עליו כמין חימום.
בבעיית הערכת הפאזה, המטרה היא לקרב
מספר ממשי מסוים ובחלק החימום הזה
נראה איך אפשר לקבל
קירוב בדיוק נמוך מאוד
למספר הזה.
זה לא יהיה
מספיק טוב לפירוק לגורמים כשנשתמש בפתרון שלנו
לבעיית הערכת הפאזה לפירוק מספרים שלמים,
בעצם נצטרך קירוב בדיוק די גבוה, אבל בכל זאת שימושי להתחיל עם מעין חימום כזה
רק כדי לקבל תחושה
איך כל העניין עובד.
אחר כך נדון בשאלה איך אפשר לקבל יותר דיוק, וזה יוביל בצורה מאוד
טבעית לפעולה שנקראת התמרת פורייה קוונטית.
נראה בדיוק מה הפעולה הזו ואיך אפשר לממש אותה
עם circuit קוונטי.
וברגע שיש לנו את זה, נוכל להשתמש
בזה להערכת פאזה כדי להגיע לתהליך כללי לפתרון הבעיה
בדיוק גבוה מאוד.
ואז בחלק האחרון של השיעור, נראה איך פתרון
לבעיית הערכת הפאזה מאפשר לנו לפרק מספרים שלמים ביעילות.
ובאופן ספציפי מה שנקבל זה האלגוריתם של Shor
לפירוק מספרים שלמים, או לפחות משהו שמקביל לאלגוריתם של Shor.
הדרך שזה עובד היא שבעצם נותנים
לעצמנו אבן דרך, שהיא עוד בעיה שנקראת בעיית מציאת הסדר.
ובפרט נראה איך אפשר לפתור את בעיית מציאת הסדר באמצעות תהליך הערכת הפאזה ואז נראה איך
אפשר לפרק מספרים שלמים
על ידי פתרון בעיית מציאת הסדר. נתחיל עם מקרה פרטי של משפט שנקרא המשפט הספקטרלי,
ובאופן ספציפי נתמקד במה שהמשפט אומר
לנו על מטריצות אוניטריות.
המשפט הספקטרלי הוא
משפט חשוב מאוד מאלגברה ליניארית
ואנליזה פונקציונלית.
הוא אומר לנו משהו מעניין על איך העתקות ליניאריות מסוימות ניתנות לביטוי בצורה מסוימת, שנקראת לעיתים קרובות
פירוק ספקטרלי,
שזה שימושי מסיבות רבות.
וכמו שאמרתי, נתמקד במה שהמשפט הזה אומר
לנו על מטריצות אוניטריות.
המשפט הספקטרלי הוא
יותר כללי מזה. הוא לא עובד לכל המטריצות, אבל הוא כן עובד למחלקה של מטריצות
שנקראות מטריצות נורמליות, שכוללות את כל המטריצות האוניטריות וגם כמה מטריצות
שאינן אוניטריות.
אבל רק כדי לשמור על פשטות, נגביל את תשומת הלב שלנו
למטריצות אוניטריות כרגע כי זה כל מה שצריך
למטרות השיעור הזה.
הנה ניסוח של המשפט הספקטרלי רק עבור מטריצות אוניטריות.
נניח ש-U היא מטריצה
אוניטרית N כפול N.
מה שהמשפט אומר
הוא שחייב להתקיים בסיס אורתונורמלי של
וקטורים, פסי אחד עד פסי N,
יחד עם N מספרים מרוכבים
למבדא אחד עד למבדא N, שכולם נמצאים על מעגל היחידה המרוכב כך ש-U ניתנת לביטוי
כמו שיש לנו במשוואה הזו.
זה נקרא פירוק ספקטרלי
של U, כפי שכבר ציינתי, וזה יכול להיות מאוד נוח לדעת ש-U ניתנת לכתיבה בצורה הזו.
לפעמים זה נוח לקבל את הוקטורים האלה ואת המספרים האלה כשעובדים עם
מטריצה אוניטרית U מסוימת, וגם יכול להיות מאוד
שימושי פשוט לדעת
שביטוי כזה תמיד אפשרי כדרך להוכיח דברים מסוימים על מטריצות אוניטריות למשל.
בניסוח הזה של המשפט, כל אחד מהמספרים האלה,
למבדא אחד עד למבדא N, כתוב בצורה מסוימת
כ-E בחזקת שתיים פי I כפול תטא כאשר כל אחת מהתטאות
תטא אחד עד תטא N היא מספר ממשי, ו
נחזור לצורה הזו
של כתיבת כל אחד מהמספרים
האלה בעוד רגע.
דבר חשוב לשים לב אליו
לגבי הוקטורים והמספרים האלה הוא שכל וקטור פסי
K חייב להיות וקטור עצמי של המטריצה U עם
ערך עצמי מתאים למבדא K.
מה שאומר שאם
נכפול את פסי K ב-U, מה שנקבל זה למבדא K כפול פסי K.
אז מה ש-U עושה לכל אחד מהוקטורים האלה זה פשוט להכפיל אותו במספר המתאים למבדא K.
באופן כללי עבור וקטור שרירותי כלשהו, ככה U לא עובד, אבל וקטורים עצמיים הם מיוחדים.
ומה שהמשפט אומר לנו הוא שבעצם קיים
בסיס אורתונורמלי של הוקטורים העצמיים האלה.
המשוואה הזו למטה אגב, נובעת מהביטוי שיש לנו ל-U מהמשפט, ביחד עם העובדה שהוקטורים
הם אורתונורמליים.
אם תכפילו את
הביטוי של U בכל פסי K ותשתמשו באורתונורמליות של הוקטורים, תקבלו סכום שבו
כל האיברים הם אפס
חוץ מאחד מהם, והאיבר היחיד שנשאר
לנו נראה ככה.
עכשיו אפשר להגדיר את
בעיית הערכת הפאזה.
הבעיה קצת
חריגה כפי שנראה.
נתונים לנו שני דברים. ראשית, נתון לנו תיאור של circuit קוונטי אוניטרי,
שפועל על N qubits
לבחירה מסוימת של N, וכשאנחנו אומרים שזה
circuit אוניטרי,
הכוונה שכל ה-gates
הם אוניטריים, אז אין מדידות
ב-circuit הזה.
שנית, נתון לנו מצב של N qubit פסי, וזה החלק החריג.
בעצם יש לנו קלט של
מצב קוונטי לבעיה הזו, וזה עותק יחיד של המצב הזה.
בכל הבעיות החישוביות האחרות שדיברנו עליהן בסדרה הזו, הקלט היה קלאסי, או בצורת מחרוזת
של ביטים או כקופסה שחורה.
וזה לא מפתיע כי הבעיות החישוביות
שאנחנו נתקלים בהן בחיי היום-יום נוטות להיות קלאסיות,
כי אלה הבעיות
שהכי אכפת לנו מהן.
הדרך שאפשר
לחשוב על הבעיה הזו היא שזה משהו שמופיע או צפוי להופיע כתת-בעיה.
ותהליך הערכת הפאזה שנגיע אליו בסוף הוא משהו
שבדרך כלל משתמשים בו כתת-שגרה
בתוך חישוב גדול יותר, ככל הנראה עבור בעיה קלאסית
שאכפת לנו ממנה.
עכשיו, זו תהיה בעיית הבטחה והמצב פסי הוא לא
סתם מצב קוונטי כלשהו.
מובטח לנו שפסי הוא וקטור עצמי של הפעולה האוניטרית U שה-circuit הנתון מתאר.
והמטרה היא למצוא או
לקרב את הערך העצמי שמתאים לוקטור העצמי פסי.
בואו ננסח את הבעיה
בצורה קצת יותר מדויקת.
הקלט מורכב מ-circuit
קוונטי אוניטרי על N qubits, שאפשר לקודד כמחרוזת של ביטים
בכל שיטה שנעדיף לקידוד תיאורי circuit קוונטיים, יחד עם מצב של N qubit פסי.
אפשר לקרוא ל-circuit איך שרוצים, אבל מה שחשוב באמת מבחינת הניסוח של הבעיה הזו זה הפעולה האוניטרית עצמה
שמתבצעת כשמריצים את ה-circuit, והפעולה האוניטרית הזו
מתוארת על ידי המטריצה U.
אבל U לא נתון לנו כמטריצה, רק נתון לנו תיאור של circuit קוונטי שמממש את U.
ההבטחה, כפי שכבר ציינתי, היא שפסי הוא וקטור עצמי של U.
אז אם היינו מריצים את ה-circuit שלנו על פסי, היינו מקבלים את פסי חזרה מוכפל בערך העצמי,
שיהיה פאזה גלובלית
במצב הזה.
ולבסוף, הפלט של הבעיה הוא קירוב לערך העצמי המתאים לפסי, ובאופן ספציפי אנחנו מחפשים
קירוב למספר הממשי תטא, בין אפס לאחד, כולל
אפס אבל לא כולל אחד
שמקיים את המשוואה
שיש לנו על המסך.
כדי להסביר את הדרך הזו
של פרמטריזציה של הערך העצמי המתאים לפסי, וגם כדי להבהיר מה הכוונה בקירוב,
בואו נצייר תמונה של
מעגל היחידה המרוכב.
אפשר לשים את המספרים אחד, I,
מינוס אחד, ומינוס I במקומות הרגילים שלהם ואפשר להסתכל על
נקודה שרירותית כלשהי על
המעגל שמפורמטרת על ידי תטא כמו בניסוח הבעיה.
זו הנקודה שמקבלים
אם מתחילים באחד ומסתובבים בזווית של
שתיים כפול פי כפול תטא, אז הזווית היא לא
תטא, היא שתיים פי תטא,
ודרך אחרת לחשוב על זה היא שאם מתחילים באחד ועוברים מרחק של שתיים פי תטא על המעגל עצמו,
נגיע לנקודה שלנו, E בחזקת
שתיים כפול פי כפול תטא.
כל נקודה על מעגל היחידה המרוכב ניתנת לייצוג בצורה הזו
לבחירה ייחודית של תטא.
וזה בגלל שעוברים
את כל המעגל כשתטא הולך מאפס לאחד, ואם היינו הולכים עד
תטא שווה אחד,
היינו חוזרים למקום שהתחלנו
בתטא שווה אפס, אז לכן כוללים אפס אבל לא כוללים אחד.
רק כדי לוודא שכל
נקודה על מעגל היחידה המרוכב מתאימה לערך ייחודי של תטא בטווח שאנחנו מסתכלים עליו.
יש דרכים שונות
שאפשר לדמיין קירוב של ערך מסוים של תטא, אבל הדרך שנעשה את זה היא לקרב את תטא עם שבר,
כאשר המכנה
הוא שתיים בחזקת M לבחירה מסוימת של מספר שלם חיובי M, והמונה הוא מספר שלם y
בין אפס לשתיים בחזקת M מינוס אחד.
אפשר לחשוב על זה כקירוב של M ביטים לתטא אם רוצים, ואפשר לכתוב את המספר הזה
בייצוג בינארי
כאשר יש נקודה בינארית אחריה הייצוג הבינארי
של Y.
אני אומר נקודה בינארית אגב
ולא נקודה עשרונית כי עשרוני זה בסיס 10 ואני מדבר על בסיס שתיים
פה, אבל זה אותו רעיון.
אבל בכל מקרה אפשר
גם פשוט לחשוב על זה כשבר כמו שמופיע
על המסך.
וכדי להבהיר, כשחושבים על
קירובים בהקשר הזה, צריך להבין
שערכים של תטא
קרובים לאפס וערכים של תטא קרובים לאחד הם בעצם קרובים זה לזה.
אז למשל, אם תטא שווה 0.99 ואנחנו מקרבים את הערך הזה
של תטא לערך אפס,
אז זה קירוב די טוב במובן שהוא
בתוך אחד ממאה מהערך האמיתי, כש
עוטפים סביב המעגל
וחוזרים לאפס כשמגיעים לאחד.
המונח מודולו אחד משמש לפעמים לתיאור המצב, שבו בעצם
משווים תטא שווה אחד עם תטא שווה אפס.
הנקודה היא שמה שבאמת אכפת לנו ממנו זה המיקום של הנקודה
E בחזקת שתיים פי I תטא על מעגל היחידה,
ולחשוב על הדרך הזו
של קירוב תטא הגיוני כשזו המטרה שלנו.
ניסוח הבעיה עצמו,
כפי שהוא מופיע על המסך, לא מפרט כמה טוב הקירוב לתטא צריך להיות,
אבל זה משהו שאפשר לכוונן בהתאם לצרכים שלנו.
במצבים מסוימים אפשר להסתפק בקירוב בדיוק נמוך
לתטא, ובמצבים אחרים אפשר לדרוש
קירוב בדיוק גבוה מאוד, ואת ניסוח הבעיה עצמו
אפשר לחדד בהתאם.
בהמשך נראה איך אפשר לפתור
את בעיית הערכת הפאזה עם מחשב קוונטי ו
נתחיל עם חימום.
זה לא יהיה הפתרון הסופי
שלנו לבעיה.
מה שנעשה זה להשתמש בתופעת בעיטת הפאזה כדי לנסות ללמוד משהו
על הערך העצמי המתאים לוקטור עצמי נתון.
נזכיר שבבעיית
הערכת הפאזה נתון לנו תיאור
של circuit קוונטי אוניטרי עבור פעולה U כלשהי,
ומה שעושים קודם כל זה
להשתמש בתיאור ה-circuit הזה כדי ליצור circuit חדש שמממש פעולת controlled U כמו
שמצויר על המסך.
זה די פשוט לעשות. מה שאפשר לעשות זה להוסיף qubit בקרה, שמצויר
בחלק העליון בתרשים הזה
ולהשתמש ב-qubit הבקרה החדש הזה
כבקרה לכל gate יחיד שמופיע
ב-circuit שלנו.
אז כל ה-gates מופעלים אם qubit הבקרה הזה מוגדר לאחד, ואף אחד מהם לא מופעל אם qubit הבקרה מוגדר לאפס,
מה שאומר שנצטרך
גרסה מבוקרת של כל gate שמופיע
ב-circuit של U, אבל לא צריך לחשוב
על ה-gates המבוקרים החדשים האלה
כ-gates בודדים אם לא רוצים. אפשר לממש אותם
כ-circuits קטנים שמורכבים מ-gates מתוך כל קבוצת gates
שבחרנו להשתמש בה. וברגע שיש לנו
גרסה מבוקרת של U, אפשר להסתכל על הרצת ה-circuit הזה,
כאשר קודם שמים את qubit הבקרה בסופרפוזיציה של אפס ואחד, מפעילים את ה-gate controlled U על הוקטור העצמי פסי שנתון לנו,
ואז מפעילים Hadamard gate
על הבקרה ומודדים.
נראה למה הגיוני לעשות את זה כשנעבור על הניתוח, אבל עוד לפני שנגיע לפרטים, אפשר מיד לראות דמיון
עם האלגוריתם של Deutsch למשל, שם מפעילים
כמה Hadamard gates ומודדים כדרך
לבדוק למעשה
מה שפעולה נתונה כלשהי
עושה כאן.
זו פעולה אוניטרית מבוקרת
ולא gate שאילתה, אבל יש רעיונות מאוד דומים בפעולה.
אז בואו נראה מה ה-circuit עושה.
המצב ההתחלתי הוא הוקטור העצמי פסי, בטנזור עם מצב
האפס עבור qubit הבקרה,
הפעלת ה-Hadamard gate הראשון מעבירה את המצב של
ה-qubit העליון למצב פלוס ואפשר לפרוש את כל
המצב כמו שמוצג כאן.
אחר כך מפעילים את פעולת ה-controlled U ומה שזה עושה זה להפעיל U על פסי כש-qubit הבקרה מוגדר לאחד,
אבל לא כשהוא מוגדר לאפס. אז מקבלים את המצב פי שתיים
שכתוב על המסך.
אפשר לפשט את המצב
בעזרת העובדה שפסי הוא וקטור עצמי של U עם ערך עצמי E בחזקת שתיים פי I תטא.
אז מקבלים את הערך העצמי הזה שמכפיל את האיבר
השני, אבל לא את הראשון.
ואפשר לפשט בעזרת הביליניאריות
של מכפלת הטנזור.
אז מה שיש לנו פה זו
תופעת בעיטת הפאזה, אבל הפעם זה קורה לוקטור עצמי שרירותי כלשהו פסי של פעולה אוניטרית שרירותית U,
בניגוד לפעולת NOT שמופעלת על מצב מינוס
באופן ספציפי יותר.
אז זה המצב אחרי שפעולת ה-controlled U מופעלת.
אגב, שווה
לעצור רגע ולשים לב שהמצב של N ה-qubits התחתונים עדיין הוקטור העצמי פסי.
מה שמצוין כי זה
נותן לנו הזדמנות להשתמש בו שוב אם נבחר.
ואז ה-Hadamard gate השני מבוצע והנה המצב שמקבלים.
ולא הראיתי את כל
הפרטים של הגזירה כאן, אבל אם מפעילים את
ה-Hadamard gate ומפשטים, זה מה שאמורים לקבל.
אז זה המצב ממש
לפני המדידה.
אז אפשר להתמקד במצב הזה כדי לראות מה אפשר ללמוד
על תטא מהמדידה.
ואם מודדים את ה-qubit
העליון או ה-qubit הימני ביותר, אלה ההסתברויות שמקבלים לשתי התוצאות.
וכאן השתמשתי
בכמה נוסחאות בסיסיות שמקשרות סינוסים וקוסינוסים
לאקספוננציאלים מרוכבים כדי לבטא את ההסתברויות האלה
במונחים של סינוסים וקוסינוסים.
באופן ספציפי, ההסתברות לקבל אפס היא קוסינוס בריבוע של פי כפול תטא וההסתברות לקבל אחד
היא סינוס בריבוע של אותה זווית. וזה הגיוני
כי סינוס בריבוע ועוד קוסינוס בריבוע של
כל זווית שווה לאחד.
אז ההסתברויות שלנו
מסתכמות לאחד כמצופה.
והנה גרף של ההסתברויות האלה כפונקציה של תטא.
ליתר דיוק, זהו גרף של
ההסתברויות עצמן להבדיל מגרף שמתאר התפלגות הסתברות
בודדת למשל.
למשל, אם תטא
שווה חצי, אז ההסתברות
לקבל את התוצאה אחד שמצוירת בסגול שווה לאחד
בעוד שההסתברות
לקבל את התוצאה אפס, שמצוירת בכחול, היא אפס.
מצד שני, אם תטא שווה
רבע או שלושה רבעים, אז שתי התוצאות סבירות באותה מידה.
וכמובן לכל הבחירות של תטא, סכום ההסתברויות שווה לאחד כפי שכבר ראינו.
אז לא לומדים בדיוק מה
תטא הוא מהתהליך הזה, אבל הוא כן נותן לנו קצת
מידע על תטא.
ואם מדמיינים מצב שבו מובטח
שתטא שווה אפס או תטא שווה חצי, התהליך הזה יגיד לנו
בדיוק איזו משתי
האפשרויות זו.
אז זו דרך פשוטה שבה אפשר להשתמש בתופעת בעיטת הפאזה כדי ללמוד משהו על הערך העצמי.
אז איך אפשר ללמוד עוד
על הערך העצמי?
ובכן, זה מצב שבו אפשר לתת
לבורות להנחות אותנו.
כי באמת אין יותר מדי
דברים שאפשר לעשות.
אנחנו לא יודעים כמעט כלום
על הוקטור העצמי פסי, וגם לא יודעים
הרבה על הפעולה U.
יש לנו circuit עבור U, אבל בשביל מה שאנחנו יודעים זה
בלגן נורא ומבלבל שלא נוכל לעשות
ממנו שום שכל אם נבחן אותו.
אבל אפשרות טבעית אחת היא להריץ את ה-circuit כמה פעמים.
בפרט, אפשר לנסות לעשות בדיוק את אותו דבר שעשינו עכשיו, חוץ מזה שבמקום להפעיל רק פעולת controlled U אחת,
מפעילים את הפעולה הזו פעמיים. או שאפשר להפעיל אותה כל מספר פעמים, אבל נתחיל עם פעמיים
רק כדי לראות מה קורה.
ובכן, זה בעצם די
פשוט מה שקורה. על ידי הפעלת
פעולת ה-controlled U פעמיים, בעצם
מריבועים את הערך העצמי
כי הוא יידחף לתוך
הפאזה של ה-qubit העליון פעמיים ולא רק פעם אחת.
ולכן כשחושבים על
הסתברויות התוצאות כפונקציה של תטא, בעצם
מכפילים את התדירות.
לכל בחירה אפשרית של תטא, הסתברויות התוצאות
זהות למה שהיה אם מכפילים את תטא ואז
לוקחים את החלק השברי
כדי לקבל מספר בין אפס לאחד.
למשל, אם תטא
שווה חצי, אז הערך העצמי הוא מינוס אחד.
אז על ידי הפעלת U פעמיים בעצם מריבועים את הערך העצמי והתוצאה זהה למה שהיה עבור תטא שווה אפס.
כלומר שההסתברות
לתוצאה אפס, שמצוירת בכחול, שווה לאחד, וההסתברות לתוצאה אחד, שמצוירת בסגול, שווה לאפס.
זה מאוד פשוט, אבל בעצם אפשר לקבל
מידע נוסף על תטא ככה.
למשל, אם יודעים מראש שתטא שווה אפס או תטא שווה רבע, אז ה-circuit הזה יחשוף לנו
איזו משתי האפשרויות זו.
מצד שני, כבר לא ניתן להבדיל בין המקרה שתטא שווה אפס לבין המקרה שתטא שווה חצי.
אז התהליך הזה לא בהכרח טוב יותר מהקודם כש
היה לנו gate controlled U יחיד אבל גם על ידי הרצת ה-circuit הזה
אפשר לצבור מידע נוסף.
זה לא מיד ברור
איך המידע הנוסף שאפשר לקבל על ידי חזרה על פעולת ה-controlled U כמה פעמים
ניתן לשלב עם
המידע שמקבלים כשמבצעים אותה רק פעם אחת, ובעצם יש כמה
דרכים שאפשר להמשיך.
למשל, יש טכניקה שנקראת הערכת פאזה איטרטיבית, שכוללת הרצת circuits כמו אלה שראינו,
יחד עם כמה וריאציות קלות עליהם, כדי להגיע לקירוב של תטא.
אבל אני אתאר
את מה שאפשר לקרוא גישה יותר מסורתית, שבה משתמשים ב-circuit קוונטי אחד עם כמה qubits בקרה
ששולטים במספרים שונים
של חזרות על הפעולה האוניטרית U.
קודם אתאר איך זה
עובד עבור שני qubits בקרה ואחר כך קצת יותר מאוחר נכליל את זה ליותר משני qubits בקרה.
הנה circuit קוונטי
שמשתמש בשני qubits בקרה.
ה-qubit הבקרה העליון
שולט בפעולת U יחידה בעוד ש-qubit
השני מלמעלה שולט בשני עותקים של U.
אז מה שעושים זה משלבים את שני ה-circuits שראינו קודם, בצורה שמנצלת את העותק היחיד
של הוקטור העצמי פסי שיש לנו.
תשימו לב בכל זאת
שה-Hadamard gates אחרי פעולות
ה-controlled U הוסרו ואין עדיין מדידות.
מה שנעשה זה
לראות איך ה-circuit הזה עובד ואז נבין
מה צריך לעשות עם שני ה-qubits העליונים
כדי ללמוד כמה שיותר על הערך תטא ש
אנחנו מנסים לקרב.
אחרי שה-Hadamard gates בוצעו, קיבלנו את המצב שמוצג
על המסך.
וזו תהיה דרך נוחה לכתוב את המצב כדי
לראות מה קורה הלאה.
A אפס ו-A אחד הם ביטים, ואם חושבים על שני ה-qubits העליונים כרגיסטר של שני qubits,
אנחנו חושבים על A אפס, שמתאים ל-qubit העליון כביט הפחות משמעותי, ו-A אחד שמתאים
ל-qubit הבקרה התחתון
כביט היותר משמעותי.
אחרי שפעולת ה-controlled
U הראשונה מבוצעת, מקבלים את המצב הזה.
המצב הקלאסי שמתאים ל-qubit הבקרה העליון הוא A אפס, אז את התוצאה של בעיטת הפאזה
אפשר לבטא בצורה הזו. ואז אחרי שפעולות
ה-controlled U השנייה והשלישית
מבוצעות, מקבלים את המצב הזה.
הרעיון זהה לראשונה, חוץ מזה שהפעם מפעילים את פעולת ה-controlled U פעמיים.
אז מכפילים את A אחד בשתיים
באקספוננט כדי לשקף את זה.
ועכשיו אפשר לפשט את הביטוי הזה על ידי מחשבה על הביטים
A אחד ו-A אפס ביחד כמספר שלם בין אפס
לשלוש בייצוג בינארי.
כלומר כשחושבים
על מחרוזת שני הביטים, A אחד A אפס, כקידוד הבינארי
של מספר שלם,
מה שמקבלים זה שתיים
כפול A אחד ועוד A אפס.
וההבנה היא
שכשכותבים קט X, מדברים על X כתוב כמחרוזת בינארית באורך
שתיים בייצוג בינארי.
אז עכשיו בואו נתמקד
בשני ה-qubits הבקרה האלה כדי להבין מה אפשר
ללמוד על תטא מהם בשלב הזה.
שאר N ה-qubits עדיין
באותו מצב פסי שקיבלנו מלכתחילה, מה שזה באמת דבר
נפלא בגישה הזו
כי כמו שאמרתי קודם, אפשר להשתמש במצב הזה שוב אם רוצים לצבור עוד יותר
מידע על תטא.
אבל לבינתיים, בואו פשוט נחשוב על מה אפשר ללמוד משני
ה-qubits הבקרה האלה.
כדי לעזור לנו להבין איך להמשיך, בואו נדמיין שמובטח לנו שתטא שווה Y חלקי ארבע
עבור מספר שלם y בין אפס לשלוש.
באופן כללי, תטא לא חייב
להיות אחד מארבעת הערכים האלה, אבל זה מקרה טבעי לבחון.
ראינו בגרסה המקורית עם qubit בקרה יחיד של התהליך שאם מובטח שתטא הוא או אפס או חצי
ה-circuit היה חושף מי מהם. וגם שמנו לב שבגרסה שבה הפעלנו את
פעולת ה-controlled U פעמיים,
יכולנו להבדיל בצורה מושלמת בין המקרה שתטא שווה אפס לבין המקרה שתטא
שווה רבע.
אז אולי נקווה שעם ה-circuit החדש שלנו נוכל להבדיל בין ארבעת המקרים האלה.
בעיקרו של דבר, מה
שעושים זה להשתמש ברעיון של בעיית הבטחה
כדי לעשות את הבעיה קלה יותר, כך שנוכל לראות איך להמשיך.
וזה לא רעיון רע בכלל. אם יש בעיה ולא
יודעים איך לפתור אותה, נסו לעשות אותה קלה יותר.
אם מצליחים לפתור את הבעיה הקלה יותר, התובנה שמקבלים עשויה לעזור בפתרון הבעיה הכללית יותר.
ואם לא מצליחים לפתור את הבעיה הקלה יותר, כנראה שלא מוכנים
לבעיה הכללית יותר.
אז תמשיכו לעשות אותה קלה יותר
עד שתצליחו לפתור אותה.
בכל מקרה, נחזור לבעיה שלנו, בואו נגדיר מצב של שני qubits לכל אחד מהערכים האפשריים של Y.
במילים אחרות, פי Y שווה למצב
שמוצג בחלק העליון של המסך כאשר תטא נבחר
במיוחד להיות Y חלקי ארבע.
והנה ארבעת המצבים
האלה כתובים במפורש.
אז רק לחזור, אם
תטא שווה Y חלקי ארבע עבור Y שהוא אפס, אחד, שתיים, או
שלוש ומריצים את ה-circuit שלנו,
נישאר עם
אחד מארבעת המצבים האלה, זה שמתאים
לערך הנכון של Y.
ואנחנו רק רוצים להבין
איזה מהם זה.
והשאלה היא, האם זה אפשרי?
והתשובה לשאלה הזו היא כן, כי ארבעת המצבים האלה אורתוגונליים.
אם מחשבים את המכפלה הפנימית
בין כל זוג מהם, מקבלים אפס.
ובגלל שהם אורתוגונליים, אפשר להבדיל ביניהם בצורה מושלמת על ידי מדידה פרוייקטיבית.
ובפרט אפשר
לבטא מדידה כזו על ידי הגדרת הטלה אחת לכל וקטור כמו שיש לנו כאן.
זה תמיד עובד, בכל פעם
שיש בסיס אורתונורמלי, ואפשר לבדוק את זה
מול ההגדרות שראינו בשיעור שלוש
עבור המקרה הספציפי הזה
אם בא לכם. אז מסקנה שאפשר
לבצע את המשימה שלנו,
שהיא ללמוד את הערך של Y מהמצב שמוצג
בחלק העליון של המסך.
ואם נרצה לעשות את זה
עם circuit קוונטי, אפשר להמשיך כפי שאסביר עכשיו.
קודם כל אפשר להגדיר מטריצה אוניטרית V שהעמודות שלה הן ארבעת
הוקטורים ברשימה לפי הסדר.
למטריצה הזו תהיה הפעולה שמתוארת בתחתית המסך,
על מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי,
ואפשר לכתוב את המטריצה
כדי לראות איך היא נראית.
בגלל ש-V ממפה כל מצב בסיס סטנדרטי, קפה Y לוקטור פי Y, יש לנו שעל ידי הפעלת V דאגר,
או במילים אחרות V הפוך על פי Y נחזיר את המצב בכיוון ההפוך למצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי המתאים.
אז מה שאפשר לעשות זה להפעיל V דאגר על כל מצב שקיבלנו
מה-circuit שלנו.
ואז אם מבצעים
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי, נקבל את המספר Y
שאנחנו מחפשים, מבוטא כמחרוזת
באורך שתיים בבינארי.
לפני שנמשיך הלאה, בואו נדבר קצת יותר
על המטריצה האוניטרית V.
זו מטריצה מיוחדת ויכול
להיות שכבר ראיתם אותה.
זו המטריצה שמשויכת
לפעולה ליניארית על וקטורים ארבעה-ממדיים שנקראת התמרת פורייה בדידה.
ליתר דיוק, את התמרת פורייה הבדידה אפשר להגדיר לכל
ממד שלם חיובי, ונסתכל עליה
באופן כללי בעוד כמה רגעים.
וככה היא
נראית במיוחד כשהממד שווה ארבע.
אפשר לחשוב על
התמרת פורייה הבדידה בדרכים שונות.
אפשר לחשוב עליה באופן מופשט לחלוטין כהעתקה ליניארית על וקטורים שאפשר לייצג במטריצה.
ואפשר גם לחשוב
עליה כבעיה חישובית שבה נתון וקטור, ורוצים לחשב את התוצאה
של הפעלת ההעתקה הליניארית הזו.
מסתבר שזו בעיה חישובית
חשובה להפליא, ויש אלגוריתם יעיל מאוד לביצוע החישוב הזה
שנקרא התמרת פורייה המהירה.
למעשה, זו בעיה כל כך חשובה בעיבוד אותות למשל, שהתמרת פורייה
המהירה נחשבת על ידי רבים
לאחד האלגוריתמים הכי חשובים ומשמעותיים
שהתגלו אי פעם.
אפשר גם לחשוב על
התמרת פורייה הבדידה כפעולה קוונטית אוניטרית שאפשר להפעיל על
וקטור מצב קוונטי.
וכשחושבים עליה בצורה הזו, קוראים לה התמרת פורייה
הקוונטית, או QFT בקיצור.
מבחינה מתמטית, זה בעצם אותו דבר כמו התמרת פורייה הבדידה, אבל קוראים לה
התמרת פורייה הקוונטית
רק כדי להבהיר שזו פעולה שמופעלת על וקטור מצב קוונטי.
אז בואו נשנה את השם של המטריצה שלנו, מ-V ל-QFT ארבע כדי לשקף את העובדה
שהפעולה שהגענו אליה היא בעצם התמרת פורייה הקוונטית.
אז הנה ה-circuit המלא ללמידת הערך של Y כשמובטח לנו ש
תטא שווה Y חלקי ארבע
עבור Y שהוא אפס, אחד, שתיים, או שלוש.
ורק כדי לוודא שזה ברור, מפעילים את ההופכי
של התמרת פורייה הקוונטית, או במילים אחרות QFT ארבע דאגר
כדי למפות אחד מארבעת המצבים האפשריים בחזרה למצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי, קט Y, כך שנוכל לשחזר את Y על ידי מדידה.
אז זה ה-circuit שמקבלים
מלחשוב על גרסת ההבטחה של
בעיית הערכת הפאזה, שם מובטח שתטא
הוא אפס, רבע, חצי,
או שלושה רבעים, אבל אין שום דבר שמונע מאיתנו
מלהריץ את ה-circuit הזה
עבור ערך שרירותי של תטא.
ואם עושים את זה, הנה
ההסתברויות לארבע התוצאות
האפשריות שמקבלים.
לכל אחד מארבעת הערכים
האפשריים של Y יש צבע משלו, והגרף אומר לנו
מה ההסתברויות לכל אחד כפונקציה של תטא.
אז למשל, אם תטא
שווה שלושה רבעים, נקבל את התוצאה
שלוש בהסתברות אחד,
בעוד שההסתברויות לשלוש התוצאות האחרות כולן אפס כפי שכבר יודעים מלחשוב על גרסת ההבטחה של הבעיה.
אם תטא קרוב לשלושה רבעים אבל לא בדיוק שלושה רבעים, תהיה הסתברות שונה מאפס לתוצאות האחרות,
אבל עדיין נקבל את התוצאה
שלוש בהסתברות גבוהה.
אז למרות שתטא לא
בהכרח שווה Y חלקי ארבע, עדיין אפשר לחשוב
על התוצאה שמקבלים מהמדידות חלקי ארבע
כניחוש או
קירוב לתטא.
הניחוש עלול להיות שגוי, אבל בכל זאת הוא
מספק לנו מידע.
ודבר אחד שאפשר
ללמוד מהגרף הוא שלקירובים הטובים ביותר תמיד יש את ההסתברויות
הגבוהות ביותר.
כשאני אומר קירוב טוב ביותר, הכוונה לכל ערך של Y חלקי ארבע שהכי קרוב לערך האמיתי של תטא,
במובן מודולו אחד. המקרה הגרוע ביותר הוא שתטא נמצא בדיוק באמצע
בין שני ערכים של Y חלקי ארבע.
למשל, אם תטא שווה
שלושה שמיניות או 0.375, במקרה הזה רואים
שהקירובים
רבע ושני רבעים
או חצי טובים באותה מידה.
אז במקרה הספציפי
הזה יש בעצם שני קירובים טובים ביותר ולא אחד.
ויש סיכוי שווה לקבל את התוצאה אחד
ואת התוצאה שתיים.
שתי התוצאות האחרות אפס ושלוש, שלא נותנות קירובים
טובים לתטא כשמחלקים בארבע, כן מופיעות עם הסתברות כלשהי
שנראית בערך
מתחת ל-10% בשני המקרים.
אז התהליך הזה לא מושלם, אבל הוא כן מספק לנו מידע.
וראוי לציין
שללא קשר לתטא, תמיד מובטח לנו לדגום או את הקירוב הטוב ביותר
או אחד משני הקירובים הטובים ביותר כשיש תיקו, בהסתברות ש
נראית קצת מעל 40%.
וככל שתטא
קרוב יותר לקירוב, כך ההסתברות לראות את הערך המתאים של Y גבוהה יותר.
וזה שיפור
משמעותי לעומת שימוש ב-qubit בקרה יחיד.
זהו בעצם תהליך הערכת
הפאזה כשבוחרים להשתמש בשני qubits בקרה.
ומה שנעשה הלאה זה להכליל את
התהליך הזה בצורה טבעית, שבה לא עוצרים עם
רק שני qubits בקרה
אלא משתמשים בכמה qubits
בקרה שנבחר.
ומה שנראה הוא שעל ידי
הכללת התהליך, על ידי הוספת עוד qubits בקרה, נוכל לקבל יותר ויותר
קירובים מדויקים של תטא. וזה יהיה תהליך
הערכת הפאזה הכללי.
כדי להכליל את תהליך
הערכת הפאזה משני qubits בקרה
לכמה שנבחר, נצטרך להבין
איך התמרת פורייה הקוונטית מוגדרת לממדים אחרים.
ונצטרך גם לדון איך אפשר לממש אותה
עם circuit קוונטי.
הנה ההגדרה של התמרת
פורייה הקוונטית כשהממד הוא
מספר שלם חיובי שרירותי N.
כאן חושבים על הפעולה הזו כפעולה על מערכת שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה הם
אפס עד N מינוס אחד.
וכאן המטריצה
שמתארת את הפעולה הזו בוטאה בעזרת
סימון דיראק.
אפשר גם לתאר אותה במונחים של הפעולה שלה
על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי, רק כדי לחבר את זה עם
מה שכבר ראינו כש-N שווה ארבע.
אז ככה זה נראה
כש-N שווה אחד, שזה לא מקרה מעניין במיוחד.
הנה זה עבור N שווה שתיים, ותשימו לב שמה שמקבלים במקרה הזה זה פעולת Hadamard.
הנה התמרת פורייה
הקוונטית עבור N שווה שלוש.
עבור N שווה ארבע, שכבר
ראינו.
ולדוגמה אחרונה, הנה היא כש-N שווה שמונה.
בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו קודם
למקרה של N שווה ארבע, אלה המטריצות שמשייכים להתמרת פורייה הבדידה
לכל אחד מהממדים. אבל קוראים לה
התמרת פורייה הקוונטית כשרוצים לחשוב עליה
כפעולה קוונטית.
לפעמים אגב, הגורם המוביל של אחד חלקי שורש של N לא נכלל כשחושבים על התמרת פורייה
הבדידה כמטריצה,
אבל צריך את הגורם הזה כאן כדי לוודא שמקבלים מטריצה אוניטרית.
לפעמים גם יש סימן מינוס בכל אחד מהאקספוננטים, אבל לא תמיד.
זו בעצם רק העדפה אישית שלא משנה את הטבע
הבסיסי של ההתמרה.
אבל בכל מקרה, נגדיר את התמרת פורייה הקוונטית כפי שהיא כתובה כאן על המסך.
יש סימון מקוצר מאוד שימושי
שנפוץ ונשתמש בו
קצת מאוחר יותר בשיעור.
וזה להגדיר מספר מרוכב
אומגה N, כמו שיש לנו כאן.
באופן ספציפי כ-E בחזקת שתיים פי I חלקי N, שאפשר גם לכתוב
בעזרת סינוסים וקוסינוסים
ככה. לפעמים קוראים למספר הזה
שורש N-י של יחידה כי כשמעלים אותו
בחזקת N, מקבלים אחד.
הנה איור שמראה כמה דוגמאות.
אומגה אחד שווה אחד, אומגה שתיים שווה מינוס אחד, ואומגה ארבע שווה I.
באופן כללי כדי לקבל אומגה N, אפשר לדמיין חיתוך של מעגל היחידה ל-N חלקים שווים כאילו זו פיצה שמחלקים בין N אנשים
ואומגה N נמצא בפינה
של החלק הראשון, בהנחה שהפינה השנייה
של אותו חלק היא באחד.
אז בפרט ככל ש-N
גדל יותר ויותר, החלקים יהיו קטנים יותר ויותר, ואומגה N יתקרב
יותר ויותר לאחד.
ועכשיו אם משתמשים בסימון הזה אפשר לבטא את
התמרת פורייה הקוונטית בצורה קצת יותר נקייה.
לפעמים הסימון הזה
עוזר לשמור על דברים פשוטים כפי שנראה קורה
קצת מאוחר יותר בשיעור.
יש מימוש יעיל של circuit
קוונטי להתמרת פורייה הקוונטית
כש-N הוא חזקה של שתיים,
שנסתכל עליו עכשיו. למרות שנוטים להגדיר את
התמרת פורייה הקוונטית לכל ממד N,
נצטרך אותה רק
במקרה ש-N הוא חזקה של שתיים, כדי להכליל את
תהליך הערכת הפאזה.
המימוש ישתמש
ב-controlled phase gates שמצוירים כמו שיש לנו
כאן על המסך.
הם נראים כמו שני
פקדי בקרה מחוברים ביחד עם מספר שהוא
אלפא במקרה הזה.
והפעולה של ה-gate הזה מתוארת על ידי המטריצה שמוצגת כאן.
אלה ממש
controlled phase gates, כלומר יש לנו qubit בקרה ששולט ב-phase gate.
ראינו phase gates עוד בשיעור הראשון.
אבל עבור phase gates במיוחד, לא באמת משנה
איזה qubit הוא הבקרה ואיזה הוא המטרה.
וראינו את זה בשיעור שתיים, עבור המקרה הספציפי של Z gate.
ועכשיו שיש לנו את המושג הזה, אפשר לעבור לאיך
שאפשר לממש את התמרת פורייה הקוונטית.
המימוש רקורסיבי באופיו ואולי הדרך הכי קלה
לתאר אותו במונחים פשוטים היא לתת דוגמה שקל
להכליל.
הנה איך אפשר לעשות את זה
כש-N שווה 32.
אז יש חמישה qubits.
ליתר בהירות, אנחנו משייכים את
מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי של חמשת ה-qubits האלה למספרים השלמים בין אפס ל-31 בייצוג בינארי.
הדבר הראשון שעושים זה לבצע את התמרת פורייה
הקוונטית עבור N שווה 16 על כל ה-qubits חוץ מה-qubit
הפחות משמעותי,
שהוא זה שלמעלה. וזה החלק הרקורסיבי
של הבנייה.
אז כדי לממש את הפעולה הזו, צריך לעקוב אחרי אותו
דפוס אבל עם qubit אחד פחות.
ובמקרה הבסיסי יש
רק qubit יחיד שעבורו התמרת פורייה הקוונטית היא פשוט Hadamard gate.
ברגע שמפעילים את ה-QFT על כל ה-qubits חוץ מהעליון, מפעילים ערימה של controlled phase gates עם הפאזות שמצוינות
בתרשים.
אחר כך מפעילים Hadamard
gate על ה-qubit העליון, ומערבבים את ה-qubits קצת בעזרת כמה swap gates.
ה-swap gates האלה גורמים לתמורה מעגלית של ה-qubits שנדרשת כדי שהבנייה
תעבוד.
אפשר לעקוב אחרי בדיוק אותו דפוס לבחירות אחרות של N
בתנאי שהם חזקות של שתיים, כאשר תמיד מתחילים את
ה-controlled phase gates
עם אלפא שווה פי חלקי
שתיים עבור ה-qubit התחתון ומחלקים בשתיים כל פעם
כשזזים שמאלה בתרשים
כדי לקבל את הפאזות הבאות. עכשיו זה בכלל לא ברור
שהבנייה הזו עובדת.
ואני לא אסביר
למה היא עובדת בסרטון הזה.
אם מעניין אתכם לראות
את הפרטים למה היא עובדת, תוכלו למצוא אותם בחומר
הכתוב של השיעור.
אגיד בכל זאת
שמה שמנוצל כאן הוא המבנה הבסיסי של
התמרות פורייה בדידות
ובעצם זה בדיוק
אותו מבנה שמאפשר להתמרת פורייה
המהירה לעבוד.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שאם מסתכלים על התמרת פורייה המהירה, אפשר לחשוב עליה במונחים
של circuits קוונטיים.
וזה ה-circuit שמקבלים.
אז כמה gates צריך בסך הכל למימוש הזה?
כדי לחשב את זה, בואו נסמן ב-SM את מספר ה-gates
שצריך כשיש M qubits.
כש-M שווה אחד, צריך רק gate יחיד כי ה-QFT היא פשוט פעולת Hadamard במקרה הזה.
אם M הוא לפחות שתיים, אז אלה
ה-gates שצריך.
קודם כל צריך SM מינוס אחד gates עבור התמרת פורייה
הקוונטית על M מינוס אחד qubits, מה שהמספר הזה יהיה.
גם צריך M מינוס אחד
controlled phase gates, M מינוס אחד swap gates,
ועוד Hadamard gate אחד נוסף.
אז הנה ביטוי
של SM בשני המקרים כש-M שווה אחד
וכש-M הוא לפחות שתיים.
זו דוגמה למה שנקרא יחס נסיגה ו
הם מופיעים מאוד נפוץ בניתוח אלגוריתמים.
יחס הנסיגה הספציפי הזה
הוא מאוד פשוט ויש לו מה שנקרא
ביטוי בצורה סגורה, שאפשר לקבל על ידי סיכום.
ליתר דיוק, הערך של SM הוא סכום M
המספרים האי-זוגיים הראשונים ברצף, ששווה M בריבוע,
כפי שאולי נתקלתם בזה או שפשוט שמתם לב
לזה בשלב כלשהו בחיים.
ומסתבר שדי קל להוכיח שהנוסחה הזו נכונה באינדוקציה על M אם
מתעניינים בהוכחה פורמלית.
אז זהו. אפשר לממש את
התמרת פורייה הקוונטית על M qubits בעזרת M בריבוע gates.
רק כמה הערות
נוספות ממש מהירות.
ראשית לא באמת
צריך את כל ה-swap gates שתיארתי.
אפשר בעצם
לדחוף את כולם לסוף כל עוד מתאימים על אילו qubits ה-controlled phase gates
פועלים בהתאם.
ואם עושים את זה נצטרך רק
M חלקי שתיים swap gates בסך הכל מעוגל למטה.
עדיין תהיה עלות ריבועית, אבל את מספר ה-gates אפשר להפחית בצורה הזו בכל זאת.
והערה אחרונה היא שבעצם אפשר להפחית את העלות עוד יותר אם מוכנים להסתפק
בקירוב די טוב.
למשל, כש-M גדל, הרבה מה-controlled phase gates די קרובים
לפעולת הזהות,
ולבטל את אלה
שמאוד קרובים יכול לחסוך לנו הרבה gates תוך שעדיין מקבלים
קירוב די טוב.
גם אפשר לקרב את התמרת פורייה הקוונטית
עם circuits רדודים מאוד, כלומר כאלה עם עומק קטן, למקרה שזה משהו
שנרצה לעשות.
ועכשיו שאנחנו יודעים מה
התמרת פורייה הקוונטית היא לממדים שונים, וגם איך אפשר לממש אותה כשהממד הוא חזקה של שתיים,
אפשר לחזור לתהליך
הערכת הפאזה ולראות איך אפשר להכליל אותו כאשר משתמשים במספר
שרירותי M של qubits בקרה.
הנה איך התהליך נראה כ-circuit קוונטי עבור
בחירה שרירותית של M.
יש לנו M qubits בקרה למעלה, שמניחים שכולם
מאותחלים למצב אפס.
מפעילים Hadamard
gate על כל אחד מהם ואז כל אחד מהם
משמש כ-qubit בקרה להפעלת חזקה כלשהי של
הפעולה האוניטרית U,
כאשר מכפילים את מספר
הפעמים שמפעילים את U עבור כל qubit בקרה.
כאן בתרשים הזה ציינתי את זה על ידי הכללת החזקות
של U בתוך הקופסאות במקום להראות את ה-controlled U gate
מופעל כל כך הרבה פעמים, כדרך גם להפוך
את התרשים ליותר ברור וגם לחסוך מקום כדי
שיכנס למסך.
עכשיו הדבר הראשון שצריך לשים לב אליו
בתהליך הזה הוא שהוא עלול להיות מאוד יקר.
בפרט מכפילים
את מספר הפעמים שכל פעולת U מופעלת
עבור כל qubit בקרה.
ואם הדרך שעושים את זה היא פשוט לחזור על controlled U gate כמה פעמים שצריך,
נקבל circuit ענקי. הוא יהיה גדול באופן אקספוננציאלי
במספר M.
זו מגבלה משמעותית באופן כללי, ובפרט היא מגבילה את היכולת שלנו לקבל קירובים מדויקים
של ערכים עצמיים.
אבל במקרה הספציפי של פירוק לגורמים, שנגיע אליו בקרוב, מסתבר שיש לנו מזל ואפשר להשתמש בטריק שמאפשר לנו
להימנע מהגידול האקספוננציאלי הזה בעלות.
אבל באופן כללי עבור פעולות
אוניטריות U שרירותיות, זה לא יהיה אפשרי ו
נשלם מחיר כבד
על הגדלת
מספר ה-qubits בקרה.
אני לא אעבור
על ניתוח מפורט של ה-circuit בסרטון הזה ובמקום זאת רק אציין שיש ביטוי פשוט למדי
עבור המצב
ממש לפני המדידות שמוצג כאן על המסך.
מהמצב הזה אפשר לקבל ביטוי להסתברויות
של התוצאות השונות, ומסתבר שהוא נראה ככה.
וברגע שיש לנו את הביטוי הזה,
אפשר לנתח אותו, ובאמת הביטוי הזה
הוא כל מה שצריך כדי להמשיך.
כמו שאמרתי, אני לא אכנס
לפרטים בסרטון הזה, אבל תוכלו למצוא אותם בחומר
הכתוב של השיעור ומסתבר שזה
בעצם לא כל כך מסובך,
אז תבדקו את זה אם בא לכם. אם כן עוברים על הניתוח, מה שמגלים הוא שהמצב
לא כל כך שונה
מהמקרה של M שווה שתיים, חוץ מזה שמקבלים יותר דיוק.
בפרט, אפשר לחשוב
קודם על ההסתברות לקבל את הקירוב הכי טוב או אחד
משני הקירובים הכי טובים,
שאפשר לבטא כמו שיש לנו כאן.
אפשר להתעלם מהסמן התחתי של אחד על הערך המוחלט אם רוצים.
זה רק סימן שאפשר
להשתמש בו כדי להזכיר לעצמנו שמדברים
על קירובים על המעגל שבהם חושבים על תטא שווה אפס
ותטא שווה אחד כאותו דבר. הנקודה כאן היא
שחושבים על כל בחירה של Y שעושה Y חלקי שתיים בחזקת M
כמה שיותר קרוב לתטא.
ושוב, בדיוק כמו שהיה
למקרה של M שווה שתיים, מובטח לנו לקבל את התוצאה Y הזו בהסתברות של לפחות 40%.
למעשה, ההסתברות היא
לפחות ארבע חלקי פי בריבוע, שזה קצת יותר מ-40%.
10 הוא לא קירוב רע
לפי בריבוע כשממהרים.
וזה בעצם די מדהים. מה שמדובר עליו זה לקבל את הקירוב הכי טוב
לתטא כשבר Y חלקי שתיים בחזקת M
כאשר Y הוא מספר שלם. ומקבלים את
הקירוב הכי טוב בהסתברות גדולה מ-40%.
אפשר גם לחשוב
על קירובים שהם פחות טובים.
באופן ספציפי בואו נדמיין
ש-Y לא כל כך טוב, ובאופן ספציפי יותר בואו נניח
שיש קירוב טוב
יותר לתטא מאותה צורה שנמצא בין תטא ל-Y חלקי שתיים בחזקת M,
שאפשר לבטא כמו
שכתוב על המסך.
במקרה כזה ההסתברות
לקבל את ה-Y הזה תהיה יחסית קטנה, לכל היותר 25%.
היא בעצם תהיה נמוכה מזה, אבל 25% זה מה שמקבלים מניתוח
די פשוט, אבל זה מספיק טוב.
כדוגמה. הנה הגרף שמקבלים כשמשתמשים בשלושה qubits
בקרה במקום שניים.
הפעם אני מצייר
רק את ההסתברויות לתוצאות שלוש, ארבע, וחמש כי לא רוצה שהאיור
יהיה מבולגן מדי.
כשתטא שווה
חצי למשל, מובטח לנו לקבל את התוצאה ארבע.
ואז לוקחים את
הקירוב שלנו להיות ארבע שמיניות או חצי כי שתיים
בחזקת שלוש זה שמונה.
ובמקרה הזה אנחנו בדיוק צודקים. וכל עוד תטא קרוב יותר לחצי מאשר נגיד לשלוש
שמיניות למשל,
מקבלים את התוצאה ארבע בהסתברות גבוהה יותר
מהתוצאה שלוש.
ובהסתברות,
שוב גדולה מ-40%.
הנה הגרף כש-M שווה ארבע. והעקומות בעצם
נראות כמעט זהות, חוץ מזה שעכשיו עשינו
זום פנימה בפקטור של שתיים.
אז עכשיו התוצאות שמצוירות כוללות שבע, שמונה, ותשע ולוקחים את הקירוב להיות אחד מהמספרים האלה
חלקי 16 במקום שמונה.
ואראה עוד גרף אחד שבו מגדילים ל-M שווה חמש.
ושוב נעשה
זום פנימה בפקטור של שתיים.
והנה הוא. שוב העקומות נראות
כמעט זהות, אבל בעצם
מכפילים את הדיוק שלנו.
וכמו קודם קיבלנו את הקירוב הטוב ביותר לתטא, בהסתברות גדולה מ-40%.
זה די מדהים. אבל אם 40% לא מספיק טוב
כמדד של ביטחון,
מה שאפשר לעשות זה להריץ את התהליך מספר קטן של פעמים, ו
לקחת את השכיח מבין התוצאות, כלומר זו שמופיעה
הכי הרבה פעמים.
ואם עושים את זה, סביר מאוד שנגיע לקירוב טוב מאוד לתטא.
זכרו אגב שבכל פעם שמריצים
את תהליך הערכת הפאזה הוקטור העצמי
יוצא ללא שינוי.
אז הוא זמין לנו להריץ את התהליך
כמה פעמים ככה.
בקיצור, אנחנו אוספים
סטטיסטיקה על תטא, והנקודה היא שבעזרת זה אפשר לקבל קירוב מדויק מאוד
לתטא
עם ביטחון גבוה מאוד, ולא צריך כל כך הרבה חזרות של התהליך כדי לעשות את זה.
וככה תהליך הערכת
הפאזה עובד.
בחלק האחרון של השיעור, נשתמש בטכניקת
הערכת הפאזה לבעיית פירוק מספרים שלמים.
כפי שציינתי בתחילת הסרטון, הדרך שזה עובד היא שמסתכלים על בעיית ביניים שנקראת בעיית מציאת הסדר.
נראה איך אפשר לפתור
את בעיית מציאת הסדר בעזרת הערכת פאזה, ואחר כך נדבר בקצרה על איך פתרון בעיית מציאת הסדר
מאפשר לנו לפרק מספרים שלמים ביעילות.
החלק השני הוא קלאסי לחלוטין ואסכם רק את
הרעיון הבסיסי בסרטון הזה.
אבל בואו נתחיל עם
בעיית מציאת הסדר.
קודם כל, בואו נקבע
סימון שימושי.
לכל מספר שלם חיובי N, מגדירים ZN להיות המספרים השלמים
אפס עד N מינוס אחד.
אז למשל, Z אחד מכיל
איבר יחיד שהוא אפס, Z שתיים מכיל את האיברים אפס ואחד,
Z שלוש מכיל את האיברים אפס,
אחד ושתיים, וכן הלאה.
אז ZN זו קבוצה.
אבל אפשר גם לחשוב
עליה כיותר מקבוצה. אפשר לחשוב על פעולות חשבון כמו חיבור וכפל על ZN
על ידי הגדרתם מודולו N.
למשל, נניח
ש-N שווה שבע.
שלוש וחמש הם
איברים של Z שבע ואם מכפילים אותם מקבלים 15
שנותן שארית של
אחד אחרי חלוקה בשבע.
לפעמים מבטאים את זה על ידי כתיבה ששלוש כפול חמש
חופף לאחד מודולו שבע, כמו שכתוב כאן.
אבל אפשר גם פשוט לכתוב ששלוש כפול חמש שווה אחד.
כמובן ששלוש כפול חמש
זה בדרך כלל לא אחד, זה 15.
אבל כשברור
שעובדים ב-Z שבע כלומר שכפל
מוגדר מודולו שבע,
אפשר פשוט לכתוב
ששלוש כפול חמש שווה אחד.
עכשיו בין האיברים
של ZN לכל N חיובי, חלקם יהיו עם
GCD שווה אחד עם N
וחלקם לא. והאיברים שכן יש להם GCD שווה אחד עם N הם מיוחדים.
וכותבים ZN כוכבית כדי להתייחס לקבוצה של רק האיברים האלה.
אז למשל, הנה Z 21 כוכבית.
בין האיברים של Z 21, שיש מהם 21 כמובן, מסתבר ש-12 מהם עם GCD שווה אחד
עם 21 והשאר לא.
בפרט בכל פעם שיש
איבר של Z 21 שמתחלק או בשלוש
או בשבע, מדלגים עליו.
יש סיבות שונות
למה הקבוצה הזו מיוחדת, ואחת הסיבות היא שבכל פעם שיש איבר של ZN כוכבית
ומסתכלים על החזקות
השלמות החיוביות של המספר הזה, תמיד בסופו של דבר
נגיע למספר אחד,
כאשר בדיוק כמו קודם מדברים על כפל מודולו N.
החזקה השלמה החיובית הקטנה ביותר שנותנת אחד נקראת
הסדר של האיבר הזה.
למשל, חשבו על האיבר A שווה ארבע ב-Z 21 כוכבית.
ארבע כפול ארבע זה 16, שלא שווה לאחד מודולו 21, אבל אם מכפילים בארבע עוד פעם,
מקבלים 64, ו-64 מודולו
21 שווה אחד.
אז הסדר של ארבע מודולו 21 הוא שלוש.
להגיע לאחד ככה תמיד קורה לכל האיברים של ZN כוכבית.
ואגב, זה אף פעם לא
קורה לאיברים של ZN שלא ב-ZN כוכבית.
אז GCD שווה
אחד עם N ככה הוא גם תנאי הכרחי וגם
תנאי מספיק כדי שזה יקרה.
ורק כדי לסיים את
הדוגמה של N שווה 21, הנה החזקות
השלמות החיוביות הקטנות ביותר שעבורן זה עובד לכל
איבר של Z 21 כוכבית,
ואפשר לבדוק כל אחד מהם בנפרד.
ועכשיו אפשר לנסח
את בעיית מציאת הסדר, שהיא פשוט למצוא את הסדר של איבר נתון ב-ZN כוכבית.
ליתר דיוק, הקלט הוא
שני מספרים שלמים חיוביים A ו-N שעבורם ה-GCD שווה אחד,
והפלט הוא המספר
השלם החיובי הקטן ביותר R כך ש-A בחזקת R
חופף לאחד מודולו N,
או באופן שקול המספר
השלם החיובי הקטן ביותר R שעבורו A בחזקת R שווה אחד.
בהנחה שעושים חשבון ב-ZN.
זו נחשבת לבעיה
קשה חישובית, אין אלגוריתם קלאסי יעיל
ידוע לפתרון שלה.
וכפי שנדון הבעיה לפחות קשה כמו
פירוק מספרים שלמים במובן שאם יש לנו אלגוריתם לפתרון מציאת הסדר,
נוכל להשתמש באלגוריתם הזה כדי לפתור את בעיית פירוק
מספרים שלמים ביעילות.
למעשה, זה עובד גם בכיוון ההפוך, כלומר שאם יש לכם אלגוריתם לפירוק, אפשר להשתמש בו כדי לפתור
את בעיית מציאת הסדר.
אז שתי הבעיות הן
במובן מסוים שקולות מבחינת
הקושי החישובי שלהן.
עכשיו נראה איך אפשר לפתור
את בעיית מציאת הסדר על מחשב קוונטי
בעזרת הערכת פאזה.
כדי ליצור קשר בין הבעיות, בואו נדמיין שיש לנו מערכת שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלה היא ZN.
לכל בחירה של איבר A ב-ZN כוכבית, נגדיר פעולה
MA כמו שיש לנו כאן.
במילים מה ש-MA עושה זה להכפיל ב-A, וכאן הכפל הוא מודולו N.
ולשארית השיעור הזה, תמיד תחשבו על
ביטויים בתוך קטים כמחושבים מודולו N,
רק כדי שנשמור על פשטות ולא נצטרך להמשיך
לכתוב mod N שוב ושוב.
זו פעולה אוניטרית, אבל זה נכון
רק בגלל ש-A נמצא ב-ZN כוכבית.
אם ה-GCD של A ו-N הוא לא אחד, הפעולה הזו לא תהיה אוניטרית.
הנה דוגמה. אם N שווה 15 ו-A שווה שתיים, שנמצא ב-Z 15 כוכבית, אז
זו הפעולה של M שתיים.
ואם תבחנו את הדוגמה
הזו לכמה רגעים, תראו שמה שקורה הוא שהאיברים של ZN פשוט עוברים תמורה על ידי הפעולה הזו.
אז היא גם דטרמיניסטית וגם אוניטרית, כלומר כמטריצה, MA היא מטריצת תמורה.
והנה הרעיון המרכזי. הערכים העצמיים של MA
קשורים מאוד
לסדר של A. ועל ידי שימוש בהערכת פאזה כדי לקרב את הערכים העצמיים
האלה מספיק קרוב
אפשר לקבוע את הסדר של A. אז מה בדיוק הוקטורים העצמיים והערכים העצמיים של MA?
ובכן, לא נצטרך את כולם, נצטרך רק חלק מהם.
בואו נתחיל עם דוגמה קלה.
הנה וקטור עצמי של MA, קראנו לו פסי אפס, והוא נתון על ידי הסכום
של קט אחד, קט A,
קט A בריבוע, וכן הלאה עד קט A בחזקת R מינוס אחד, הכל חלקי שורש של R
כדי להפוך אותו לוקטור יחידה. כאן R הוא הסדר של A.
ואשמור את האות
R לסדר של A לשאר השיעור.
אז בכל פעם שרואים R, זה הסדר של A
לכל A שמדברים עליו.
הערך העצמי המשויך
לוקטור העצמי הזה הוא אחד.
ואפשר לוודא את זה על ידי
הפעלת MA על הוקטור הזה כדי לראות מה מקבלים.
MA מכפיל ב-A, אז
רק צריך להגדיל כל אחת מהחזקות
באחד וזה מה שמקבלים.
אבל הסדר של A הוא R, אז A בחזקת R שווה אחד.
ואפשר לעשות את ההחלפה הזו.
אבל זה אותו וקטור
שהתחלנו איתו. כל מה שעשינו זה
לערבב את הקטים אבל לוקחים סכום אז
זה לא משנה כלום.
אז MA כפול פסי אפס שווה פסי אפס.
אז זה וקטור עצמי של
MA עם ערך עצמי אחד.
זו דוגמה מאוד פשוטה
של וקטור עצמי וכדי לזהות עוד כאלה, בואו ניזכר באותו סימון שהיה לנו קודם בשיעור.
אומגה R הוא המספר המרוכב
על מעגל היחידה שמקבלים על ידי חישוב E בחזקת
שתיים כפול פי כפול I
חלקי R. בפעם הקודמת היה לנו N במקום R, אבל זה עדיין עובד אותו
דבר עם R במקום N.
צריך את המספר הזה כי
הוא יופיע בוקטורים העצמיים האחרים
של MA שנזהה.
ועכשיו שנזכרנו בסימון הזה, אפשר לשים לב שהוקטור
הזה שנקרא פסי אחד הוא גם וקטור עצמי של MA.
הוא דומה לפסי אפס, יש לנו בדיוק את אותם קטים ומסכמים אותם ו
מחלקים בשורש של R.
אבל הפעם יש פאזות שונות שמכפילות כל אחד מהקטים.
אומגה R בחזקת מינוס אחד עבור A, אומגה R בחזקת מינוס שתיים עבור A בריבוע, וכן הלאה עד אומגה R
בחזקת מינוס R מינוס אחד
עבור A בחזקת R מינוס אחד. אז החזקה של אומגה R
היא תמיד מינוס אחד כפול כל חזקה של A
שמופיעה בתוך הקט.
לא אעבור על זה בפירוט, אבל זה מוצג על המסך למקרה שתרצו לצפות שוב בסרטון ולעצור כשצריך.
אבל אם עושים את הכפל ומפשטים שוב בעזרת העובדה ש-A בחזקת R שווה אחד
וגם העובדה החשובה מאוד שאומגה בחזקת R שווה אחד, מה שנמצא הוא
שוב וקטור עצמי של MA.
הפעם כשמפשטים, נצטרך להוציא גורם של אומגה R כדי לראות שאכן יש לנו וקטור עצמי
ואותו גורם של אומגה R מייצג את הערך העצמי המשויך לוקטור העצמי הזה.
אז זה זוג וקטור עצמי-ערך
עצמי שני של MA.
אפשר לזהות וקטורים עצמיים נוספים בדיוק באותו היגיון, ולמעשה, אם פשוט מחליפים את אומגה R
באומגה R בחזקת J לכל J בין אפס ל-R מינוס אחד, תמיד נקבל וקטור עצמי,
והערך העצמי המשויך יהיה אומגה R בחזקת J.
אז זה בעצם כולל
את פסי אפס ופסי אחד, שכבר ראינו
וגם R מינוס שתיים זוגות נוספים של וקטור עצמי, ערך עצמי.
כולם עובדים בעצם באותו אופן, וכדי לאמת אותם, רק צריך לדעת ש-A בחזקת R שווה אחד
וגם שאומגה R
בחזקת R שווה אחד.
יש וקטורים עצמיים אחרים של MA כמו קט אפס למשל, אבל הם לא יהיו שימושיים לנו ולא צריך לדאוג מהם.
צריך לדאוג רק מפסי אפס עד פסי R מינוס אחד.
בואו נתמקד בפסי אחד לרגע, רק כדי לנסות להבין למה אכפת לנו מהוקטורים העצמיים האלה
ומה הם יכולים לספר
לנו על הסדר R, שזה מה שאנחנו מנסים למצוא.
בהנחה שנתון
לנו הוקטור העצמי פסי אחד, אפשר לנסות ללמוד
את R בדרך הבאה.
ראשית, מבצעים הערכת
פאזה על הוקטור העצמי הזה בעזרת circuit קוונטי ש
מממש את הפעולה MA.
מה שמקבלים זה קירוב לתטא, שהוא אחד חלקי R במקרה הזה.
ושנית כי אנחנו מחפשים R ויש לנו
קירוב לאחד חלקי R, הדבר הטבעי לעשות זה
לחשב את ההופכי
ולעגל את זה
למספר השלם הקרוב ביותר. צריך לעגל ככה
כי R חייב להיות מספר שלם.
אבל אין לנו בדיוק אחד חלקי R, יש לנו רק קירוב לזה.
אבל אם הקירוב מספיק טוב, נקבל R כשנעגל,
שזה מה שאנחנו מחפשים.
ועכשיו השאלה היא כמה דיוק צריך כדי לקבוע את R בצורה נכונה על ידי חישוב ההופכי ועיגול?
או במילים אחרות, כמה מדויק צריך
הקירוב שלנו להיות כדי שכל זה יעבוד?
ובכן, מסתבר שכן צריך קירוב די מדויק.
למשל, אי אפשר
להרשות לעצמנו לבלבל בין אחד חלקי R לבין אחד חלקי R פלוס אחד, או אחד חלקי R מינוס אחד למשל.
בשני השברים האלה, אחד חלקי R פלוס אחד ו
אחד חלקי R מינוס אחד, די קרובים לאחד
חלקי R כש-R גדול.
אבל למרות שצריך
קירוב די מדויק, לא צריך
קירוב מדויק באופן מגוחך, ואפשר להראות
שאם הקירוב שלנו
מקיים את אי-השוויון
שיש לנו כאן על המסך, אז עיגול
ייתן לנו את התשובה הנכונה.
לא אנסה להוכיח את זה בסרטון הזה, אבל זה מוצג בחומר הכתוב
של השיעור למקרה שמעניינים אתכם הפרטים.
ואם זה הדיוק
שאנחנו שואפים אליו, אז מספיק להשתמש
במספר של qubits בקרה בתהליך הערכת הפאזה
ששווה פעמיים אורך
N ועוד אחד.
כאשר כמו שהיה לנו בשיעורים הקודמים, אורך N הוא מספר הביטים שצריך כדי לבטא את N בבינארי.
אגב, אם מסתפקים
בלקבל את הקירוב הטוב ביותר בהסתברות של לפחות 40% ולא מנסים להגדיל
את הביטחון שלנו
כפי שתיארתי קודם, אז בעצם לא צריך את הפלוס אחד.
אבל בכל מקרה, יש לנו שמספר
ה-qubits בקרה שצריך הוא ליניארי באורך של N
כתוב כמחרוזת בינארית.
ראינו שאם יש לנו
את הוקטור העצמי פסי אחד, אפשר להשתמש בהערכת פאזה כדי למצוא R, בתנאי שמשתמשים בדיוק מספיק.
למרבה הצער זה לא כל כך קל להשיג את הוקטור העצמי הזה.
אז בואו נשאל שאלה אחרת.
נניח שאין לנו את פסי אחד, אלא יש לנו פסי J
לבחירה אקראית של J.
האם עדיין אפשר להבין מה R? או לפחות האם אפשר
להבין משהו על R?
והתשובה היא כן, אפשר להבין משהו
על R, לפחות בממוצע.
מה שאפשר לעשות זה לנסות
להבין J חלקי R בעזרת שיטה מאוד דומה
לזו שזה עתה ראינו,
אבל עם הבדל מפתח.
ראשית, נעשה בדיוק את
אותו דבר שעשינו קודם, שזה להריץ את תהליך
הערכת הפאזה על הוקטור העצמי פסי J.
ומה שנקבל זה
קירוב ל-J חלקי R, בניגוד לאחד חלקי R,
שזה מה שהיה לנו קודם.
אבל עכשיו יש לנו בעיה קטנה, כי חישוב
ההופכי לא ייתן לנו R, הוא ייתן לנו R חלקי J.
ואגב, אנחנו לא
מניחים שיודעים מה J, פשוט נתון לנו פסי J עבור J אקראי,
ולא אמרו לנו מה J. אז מה אפשר לעשות?
ובכן, מסתבר שיש אלגוריתם קלאסי
ידוע שיכול לעזור לנו, שנקרא
אלגוריתם השברים המשולבים.
ומה שהאלגוריתם הזה יכול לעשות זה לקחת את הקירוב שלנו
Y חלקי שתיים בחזקת M ולספר לנו איזה שבר U חלקי V,
כתוב בצמצום, כאשר U ו-V שניהם
מספרים שלמים קטנים מ-N הוא הכי קרוב לקירוב שלנו.
זה אלגוריתם ממש מרתק, ואם מעניין אתכם, בהחלט כדאי לבדוק אותו.
הוא קשור מאוד לאלגוריתם של אוקלידס לחישוב
GCD למעשה.
אבל לא אגיד עוד
משהו עליו בסרטון הזה.
הנקודה היא שאם יש לנו קירוב טוב
לשבר כלשהו שהמונה
והמכנה שלו לא גדולים מדי,
האלגוריתם יכול לשחזר את השבר, וזה מה שעושים כאן.
ועכשיו נשארנו עם בדיוק
אותה שאלה כמו קודם, שהיא כמה דיוק צריך?
ומסתבר שבדיוק
אותו חסם שהיה לנו קודם עובד גם במקרה הזה.
ולכן בחירת M בדיוק
באותו אופן כמו קודם עובדת גם כאן.
עכשיו זה לא בהכרח
יגיד לנו מה R.
מה שנלמד אם נשתמש
בדיוק מספיק, זה J חלקי R, אבל זה יהיה
שבר בצמצום.
אז יכול להיות לנו חוסר מזל במובן שהבחירה האקראית הזו של J יכולה לחלוק גורמים משותפים עם R,
והם יהיו מוסתרים מאיתנו. במקרה הגרוע ביותר למשל, יכולים לקבל J שווה אפס ואז לא נלמד כלום.
אבל זה ממש המקרה היחיד
שבו לא לומדים כלום.
באופן כללי, לפחות
נקבל גורם לא-טריוויאלי של R, ואם מסוגלים לדגום דגימות אקראיות
ולקבל פסי J לבחירות שונות של J, בעצם אפשר לשחזר
את R בהסתברות גבוהה על ידי חישוב הכפולה המשותפת המינימלית
של כל המכנים
שצופים בהם. וזה בעצם לא
דורש הרבה דגימות בכלל.
השורה התחתונה היא שכמה בחירות של J יסתירו גורמים של R, אבל בחירות אקראיות של J
לא יוכלו להסתיר את
הגורמים של R לאורך זמן.
אז זה הרעיון. נשאר לשקול את המימוש ובפרט להבין
כמה זה עולה.
המהות של הרעיון, לחשב את הסדר של
איבר נתון A ב-ZN כוכבית היא להפעיל את תהליך הערכת הפאזה
על הפעולה MA.
בואו נבין מה
העלות של לעשות את זה כפונקציה של אורך N הגדול, שאסמן ב-n הקטן.
הנה circuit להערכת פאזה. נצטרך n קטן qubits בחלק התחתון של ה-circuit
כדי לקודד איברים של ZN בבינארי. אז יש לנו N qubits בקרה למעלה ו-n קטן qubits למטה,
מה שנחמד כי זה מתאים לשמות
שהשתמשנו בהם קודם בשיעור.
כדי לספור את
מספר ה-gates שצריך ל-circuit כולו, בואו נתמקד קודם בעלות של הפעולות האוניטריות המבוקרות.
אם משתמשים בטכניקות
מהשיעור הקודם, שיעור שש, אפשר לממש MA בעזרת O גדול של n קטן בריבוע gates
בעזרת אלגוריתמים קלאסיים יעילים לחשבון מודולו N.
אדלג על הפרטים בסרטון הזה, אבל כמו כמה דברים
אחרים שדיברתי עליהם, אפשר לקרוא עוד על זה בחומר הכתוב של השיעור.
אבל לא מספיק
לממש רק MA.
צריך גם לממש MA בריבוע, MA בחזקת ארבע,
בחזקת שמונה, וכן הלאה
עד MA בחזקה שהיא אקספוננציאלית ב-M.
ואנחנו יודעים שנצטרך לקחת M להיות ליניארי ב-n קטן
כדי לקבל מספיק דיוק.
זו דאגה גדולה,
והעליתי אותה קודם.
אם היינו ממשים חזקות
של MA פשוט על ידי חזרה על MA, היינו בבעיה כי כל החזרות האלה על MA
היו גורמות לעלות אקספוננציאלית.
למזל, אפשר להשתמש בטריק כדי להימנע מהגידול הזה בעלות.
מה שאפשר לעשות הוא כדלקמן, לכל חזקה K שצריך.
ראשית, מחשבים A
בחזקת K, מודולו N.
זו בעיית ההעלאה בחזקה מודולרית שהזכרתי בשיעור שש.
ואפשר לפתור אותה ביעילות. וזה משהו שאפשר לעשות עם מחשב קלאסי.
החישוב הזה לא
צריך להתבצע על ידי circuit קוונטי בכלל.
אז בואו נסמן ב-B את התוצאה.
אז B הוא איבר של ZN כוכבית.
ושנית, במקום MA בחזקת K, פשוט משתמשים ב-circuit עבור MB.
וזהו. B הוא סתם איבר של ZN כוכבית, אז העלות לממש MB
היא O גדול של n קטן בריבוע.
בקיצור, מה שעושים זה מעלים בחזקה ב-ZN במקום להעלות בחזקה
circuit קוונטי.
אבל הפעולה בפועל שמקבלים
היא אותו דבר בכל מקרה. זה פשוט כפל ב-A, K פעמים.
זה כמו נס למעשה. ולא היינו מסוגלים
לפתור את בעיית מציאת הסדר או לפרק מספרים שלמים ביעילות
עם מחשב קוונטי
אלמלא זה.
ועכשיו שאנחנו יודעים שכל אחת מהפעולות
האוניטריות המבוקרות, כולל החזקות, ניתנת למימוש
בעלות O גדול של n בריבוע, אפשר לספור את מספר
ה-gates הכולל שצריך.
יש לנו N Hadamard gates, ובגלל ש-M שווה
O גדול של n קטן, העלות היא O גדול של n קטן.
יש לנו M פעולות אוניטריות מבוקרות שלכל אחת עלות O גדול של n בריבוע.
אז העלות הכוללת כאן
היא O גדול של n בשלישית.
ולבסוף, התמרת פורייה הקוונטית עולה O גדול של n בריבוע.
אז העלות הכוללת היא O גדול של n בשלישית.
בפרט, רואים שגם עם הטריק של
העלאה בחזקה מודולרית שלנו, העלות של הפעולות האוניטריות
המבוקרות שולטת.
אבל בכל זאת, העלות
היא פולינומית ב-n קטן.
יש גם כמה חישובים
קלאסיים נדרשים, כמו חישוב ההעלאות בחזקה מודולריות והרצת אלגוריתם
השברים המשולבים,
אבל החישובים האלה
גם הם בעלות פולינומית. ולמעשה, אפשר לעשות אותם ב-O גדול של n בשלישית פעולות גם כן.
נשארה רק בעיה אחת, וזה שצריך להשיג אחד מהוקטורים העצמיים האלה.
איך אפשר לעשות את זה?
הפתרון בעצם מאוד פשוט. לא מריצים את ה-circuit
על וקטור עצמי.
פשוט מריצים אותו על המצב אחד, כלומר הקידוד הבינארי
של המספר אחד, שאנחנו חושבים
עליו כאיבר של ZN.
אז בואו נעשה את
ההחלפה הזו בתרשים.
הסיבה שזה עובד היא בגלל המשוואה הזו כאן.
המצב קט אחד הוא
בעצם סופרפוזיציה אחידה של R הוקטורים העצמיים
שדיברנו עליהם.
וזה לא מיד ברור, אבל אם מחשבים את
הסכום, אמורים לקבל קט אחד.
ואם מריצים את ה-circuit על המצב הזה, הפלט שנקבל
יהיה בדיוק כאילו בחרנו באקראי J
והרצנו את התהליך על
הוקטור העצמי פסי J.
שוב, זה לא מובן מאליו, אבל ניתוח מגלה שזה נכון.
ולבסוף, זהו. יש לנו אלגוריתם קוונטי
יעיל למציאת הסדר.
נשאר חלק אחד קצר מאוד
של השיעור והוא נוגע ליחס בין פירוק מספרים שלמים
למציאת הסדר.
ציינתי שאם אפשר לפתור את בעיית מציאת הסדר ביעילות, אז אפשר גם לפרק
מספרים שלמים ביעילות.
ואני רוצה בקצרה מאוד לתת לכם את הרעיון המרכזי איך זה עובד.
זה קלאסי לחלוטין. לחלק הזה בעצם אין
שום קשר למחשוב קוונטי.
הנה שיטה למצוא
גורם לא-טריוויאלי של מספר שלם חיובי נתון N.
ואגב, השיטה הזו עובדת רק כש-N הוא מספר אי-זוגי, והוא לא מספר
ראשוני מועלה בחזקה.
את שני המקרים האלה כש-N
זוגי או חזקה של ראשוני אפשר לטפל בנפרד.
יש שיטות קלאסיות יעילות גם לזיהוי וגם
לטיפול בשני המקרים האלה.
השיטה הזו הסתברותית. היא עלולה להיכשל, אבל
ההסתברות לכישלון תהיה לכל היותר חצי,
ואפשר פשוט להריץ אותה
כמה פעמים באופן עצמאי כדי להפחית את הסתברות
השגיאה באופן אקספוננציאלי.
ראשית, בוחרים A בין
שתיים ל-N מינוס אחד באקראי, אחיד.
אחר כך מחשבים את ה-GCD של A ו-N.
ואם ה-GCD
יוצא גדול מאחד, אז פשוט היה לנו מזל ברמות.
ה-GCD יהיה גורם של N ואפשר פשוט להוציא אותו כפלט ולעצור.
אחרת, האלגוריתם ממשיך ועכשיו יודעים ש-A נמצא ב-ZN כוכבית.
ועכשיו מחשבים את הסדר של A, ושם צריך מחשב קוונטי.
או אולי יש דרך אחרת
לחשב את הסדר. לאלגוריתם לא באמת
אכפת מאיפה זה בא, אבל הדרך היחידה שאנחנו יודעים
לעשות את זה ביעילות
היא עם מחשב קוונטי.
אם הסדר R זוגי, אז מחשבים את ה-GCD של
A בחזקת R חלקי שתיים מינוס אחד עם N.
ואם ה-GCD הזה גדול מאחד, אז שוב יש לנו גורם של N, אז מוציאים אותו כפלט ועוצרים.
אחרת האלגוריתם נכשל. ובמקרה הזה,
אפשר לחזור להתחלה ולבחור A אחר
ולקוות לתוצאה טובה
יותר בפעם הבאה.
וזהו. ואגב, ברגע
שמצאנו גורם של N, אפשר לעשות רקורסיה גם על הגורם הזה
וגם על N חלקי הגורם עד שיש לנו פירוק לגורמים ראשוניים של N.
אז למה זה אמור לעבוד?
ובכן, יש שתי נקודות עיקריות. הראשונה היא שבגלל ש-A בחזקת R חופף לאחד מודולו N,
יש לנו ש-N מחלק את A
בחזקת R מינוס אחד.
שתי ההצהרות האלה
בעצם שקולות. זו ההגדרה של mod N שתמצאו בספרי תורת המספרים.
שנית, אם R זוגי, אז המשוואה
שיש לנו כאן נכונה.
זו הנוסחה הידועה
להפרש ריבועים.
למעשה, המשוואה נכונה לכל R, אבל צריך ש-R חלקי שתיים
יהיה מספר שלם בשלב ארבע.
ואם שמים את שתי העובדות ביחד, רואים שכל גורם ראשוני של N חייב לחלק אחד משני
הביטויים בסוגריים,
כי זו הדרך היחידה
ש-N יכול לחלק את המכפלה.
עכשיו, ייתכן שכל
גורם ראשוני של N מחלק את הביטוי
הראשון בסוגריים ולא את השני, אבל עבור ה-A האקראי שלנו,
זה לא מאוד סביר. ולכן כשמחשבים
את ה-GCD בשלב ארבע, סביר שנקבל את המכפלה
של חלק מהגורמים הראשוניים
של N, אבל לא כולם.
לנתח את זה בזהירות
דורש קצת תורת מספרים, אבל זו תורת מספרים בסיסית למדי.
אז אם תורת מספרים
מעניינת אתכם ואתם רוצים ללמוד עוד עליה, נסו לעבור על הניתוח הזה.
לעבור על דברים כאלה זו דרך מצוינת ללמוד עוד, אבל אני אשאיר את זה לכם.
וזה סוף השיעור. בשיעור הזה, כיסינו
את בעיית הערכת הפאזה, איך אפשר לפתור אותה ביעילות
על מחשב קוונטי,
ואיך אפשר ליישם את הפתרון כדי לקבל אלגוריתם קוונטי
בעלות פולינומית לפירוק מספרים שלמים.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי לשיעור הבא, שעוסק באלגוריתם
החיפוש הקוונטי של Grover.
להתראות עד אז.